FRIENDS" TOMORROW EARLY.
CHECK IT OUT.
TUCKER IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY FRIDAY.
THERE IS SO MUCH GOING ON
THESE DAYS.
THINGS ARE SO CRAZY.
THAT EVEN SOME OF US WHO ARE
PAID TO FOLLOW THE NEWS FOR A
LIVING FORGET TO STOP EVERY
ONCE IN A WHILE AND ASK THE
MOST OBVIOUS QUESTIONS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM.
FOR EXAMPLE, HOW DID THE PARTY
THAT HATES OLD, STRAIGHT WHITE
MEN CHOOSE AS ITS FRONT RUNNER
ONE OF THE OLDEST,
STRAIGHTEST, WHITEST MEN IN
AMERICAN POLITICS?
IT'S KIND OF REMARKABLE.
BAFFLING, ACTUALLY.
JOE BIDEN WHO IS THAT MAN MUST
BE THINKING THE SAME THING.
HOLY SMOKES!
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
WHAT CAN I DO NOT TO SCREW IT
UP?
HE IS A LUCKY MAN AND HE KNOWS
IT.
WATCHING BIDEN YOU GET THE
FEELING HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
IS GOING ON, HE DOESN'T KNOW
THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTIONS.
BIDEN IS SPRY AND ENERGETIC
BUT HE IS FROM ANOTHER
GENERATION.
BORN A YEAR YEAH BEFORE D-DAY.
IF ELECTED HE WOULD BE OLDER
ON INAUGURATION ON THE NEXT
OLDEST PRESIDENT, RONALD
REAGAN WAS, WHEN HE LEFT
OFFICE.
HE IS OLD ENOUGH TO BE
A.O.C.'S GREAT GRANDFATHER.
SO WHEN THEY THROW OUT AN
IDEOLOGICAL LITMUS TEST, JOE
BIDEN DOESN'T ARGUE.
HE JUST AGREES.
THE LATEST TEST IS ABOUT
ABORTION.
SINCE 1976 THE LAW CALLED THE
HYDE AMENDMENT PROHIBITED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PAYING FOR
ABORTION.
FOR MORE THAN 40 YEARS THE LAW
SUPPORTED STRONG POPULAR
SUPPORT.
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY SUPPORT.
INCLUDING FROM JOE BIDEN.
EVEN PEOPLE WHO CALL
THEMSELVES PRO-CHOICE
UNDERSTAND IT'S WRONG TO USE
TAXPAYERS' DOLLARS TO FUND
SOMETHING LIKE ABORTION.
BUT A SMALL GROUP OF
PROGRESSIVE ACTIVISTS
DISAGREE.
AND THEY KNOW THE CORE
POLITICAL TRUTH THAT REPEALING
THE HYDE AMENDMENT WOULD BE A
WINDFALL OF THE TAXPAYER MONEY
FOR PLANNED PARENTHOOD.
AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD FUNDS
DEMOCRATIC CAMPAIGNS.
SO IN THE LAST YEAR THEY
SUCCESSFULLY BULLIED EVERY
LEADING DEMOCRAT IN AMERICA TO
PARROTING THEIR LINE.
WATCH.
>> I WILL REPEAL THE HYDE
AMENDMENT.
IT'S THE AMENDMENT IN LAW THAT
MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR
LOW-INCOME WOMEN TO ACCESS THE
CARE THEY NEED.
>> THE HYDE AMENDMENT IS A
DIRECT ASSAULT OF THE BLACK
AND THE BROWN COMMUNITIES LIKE
THE ONES I HAVE BEEN
REPRESENTING.
>> IF YOU VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOU WILL SEE THE COMMITMENT TO
REPEALING THE HYDE AMENDMENT.
>> AS PRESIDENT I WILL MAKE
SURE THAT WE REPEAL THE HYDE
AMENDMENT.
>> I DON'T SUPPORT THE HYDE
I WILL LEAD THE FIGHT TO HAVE
IT OVERTURNED.
>> Tucker: UH-HUH.
SO, PAUSE FOR A SECOND.
THROW OUT THE RHETORIC.
TRY TO THINK THROUGH THE
REASONING.
CORY BOOKER'S REASONING FOR
EXAMPLE, IF YOU CAN CALL IT
"REASONING."
HE IS SAYING NOT USING THE TAX
DOLLAR TO PREVENT BLACK AND
HISPANIC CHILDREN BEING BORN
IS AN ASSAULT ON BLACK AND
HISPANIC NEIGHBORHOODS.
SO FOR THE RECORD, THIS IS
TRUE, CORY BOOKER HAS EXACTLY
THE SAME POSITION ON ABORTION
AS THE KU KLUX KLAN DOES.
JOE BIDEN BY CONTRAST HAD A
DIFFERENT VIEW UNTIL LAST
NIGHT.
AT A SPEECH IN ATLANTA HE
ANNOUNCED HE IS NOW IN FAVOR
OF THE TAXPAYERS-FUNDED
ABORTION.
WATCH.
>> FOR MANY YEARS AS
U.S. SENATOR, I HAVE, I HAVE
SUPPORTED THE HYDE AMENDMENT
LIKE MANY, MANY OTHERS HAVE.
BUT CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
CHANGED.
I HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH
THE PROBLEMS THAT HYDE NOW
PRESENTS.
I CAN'T JUSTIFY LEAVING
MILLIONS OF WOMEN WITHOUT
ACCESS TO THE CARE THEY NEED.
IF I BELIEVE HEALTHCARE IS A
RIGHT, AS I DO, I CAN NO
LONGER SUPPORT THE WOMEN THAT
MAKES THE RIGHT DEPENDENT ON
SOMEONE'S ZIP CODE.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT WAS A
HOSTAGE TAPE.
THE CIRCUMSTANCES HAVE
CHANGED, SAYS JOE BIDEN.
WHICH CIRCUMSTANCES?
LET'S BE SPECIFIC.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT TODAY IN
"THE ATLANTIC," BIDEN CHANGED
HIS MIND AFTER THE CAMPAIGN
TOOK A CALL FROM ALYSSA MILANO
THE LEFT WING ACTRESS AND
PROFESSIONAL UNHAPPY PERSON.
IF SHE WANTS TAXPAYERS FUNDED
ABORTION, JOE BIDEN WILL
DELIVER IT.
WHATEVER IT TAKES.
IT DOES MAKE YOU WONDER, WHAT
WOULDN'T BIDEN DO?
MA ARE HIS LIMITS?
IS THERE ANY PROPOSAL THAT JOE
BIDEN WOULDN'T GET BEHIND AS
LONG AS IT SOUNDED NEW AND HIP
AND PROGRESSIVE?
FOR EXAMPLE IF THE WOKE
COMMUNITY DEMANDED A BAN ON
HETEROSEXUAL MARRIAGE, WOULD
JOE BIDEN SUPPORT THAT?
HOW ABOUT THE TRANSGENDER
ANIMAL RIGHTS?
IS HE FOR THOSE?
WHATEVER THEY ARE.
WHERE IS JOE BIDEN ON THE
TESTOSTERONE TAX TO FIGHT
GLOBAL WARMING.
THAT SOUNDS PROGRESSIVE.
FEDERALLY FUNDED TAMPON
DISPENSERS IN MEN'S ROOM.
FOR THE RECORD WE MADE UP MOST
OF THE ISSUES.
THEY'RE NOT REAL.
BUT THEY SOUND REAL.
THIS IS 2019.
SOON THEY MAY BE REAL.
WE CALLED TO THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN TO SEE WHERE THE
CANDIDATE STANDS ON THOSE
THINGS.
THEY HAVEN'T RESPONDED YET.
BUT IF TOMORROW YOU WAKE UP
AND READ BIDEN ENDORSES